who doesn't love a good old 3d movie
let's all go to the lobby
do you know what I hate is when
producers make me wear silly props that
make me look like an idiot but you know
who doesn't look stupid in 3d glasses
are these tiny praying mantises for the
past six years researchers at Newcastle
University have been strapping tiny 3d
glasses onto these little critters to
study how their 3d vision might work and
how they might apply those findings to
robots
I'm Jenny Reed and professor of vision
science at the Institute of Neuroscience
Newcastle University UK to learn more we
caught up with Jenny Reed who's leading
this research tell us about this system
that you are saying so I'm studying
praying mantises and in particular how
they do 3d or stereoscopic vision so you
use the different views at your 2ic to
work out how far away things up and
that's an ability that was only
discovered in humans in the 19th century
and used to be thought you know really
complicated and only hire mammals like
humans and monkeys maybe cats can do but
back in the 1980s it was discovered that
actually insects have this ability as
well or at least one insect the praying
mantis so when I heard about that I got
really interested in thought we need to
find out how that works how is these
tiny insect brains achieving
stereoscopic vision are they doing it in
the same way as we do which would be
really interesting because I think then
that would tell us that there's only one
good way of doing stereo vision but the
other possibility is that maybe the
insects have evolved a completely
separate way of doing stereo vision in
that case that would also be really
fascinating to find out how they've done
it and maybe get new ideas for how you
can achieve stereoscopic vision genes so
this is one of my favorite methodologies
of all time can you talk about how you
went about studying this system how you
went about attaching 3d glasses to
mantises so that was the first puzzle
that we had to solve when we were
beginning this study so I mentioned the
initial research in the 1980s on insect
3d vision that used prisms and it's a
really beautiful
technique and because prisms been the
light rays that has the effect of
basically stereoscopically moving
everything either closer or further away
but we couldn't use that for the
experiments I wanted to do because in
order to answer these questions we
needed to present much more complicated
3d images to it so I needed to find some
way of presenting 3d images just like we
do for humans so we spend a lot of time
trying various techniques but in the end
the only one that's actually worked for
us is using colored filters you might be
familiar with these red blue 3d glasses
that I dunno used to get into cereal
packets when I was a kid and in the 3d
movies back in the fifties that
technology's kind of been superseded for
humans but for the insects it still
works really well the only thing is we
didn't want to use red light because
insects most of them including mountains
don't see red lights at all it's just
not a wavelength that they're sensitive
to so we shifted everything towards
shorter wavelengths and we use blue and
green light so the idea is we have a
computer monitor and we display the left
image say on the blue channel and the
light image on the green Channel and
then with these colored filters we
ensure that each eye the insect sees
only the appropriate Channel and that's
work done by my Bo talented postdoc
vivek nityananda and he spent so much
time figuring out how to achieve this
and ironing out all the problems that we
encountered along the way and of course
as you say the big problem is how do you
attach glasses to an insect right limit
of any years you could put glasses on
with a super vet came up with a harmless
form of glue made out of beeswax and
resin so natural ingredients that aren't
going to harm the animal and with a wax
melter he just melts a little dog of
beeswax places it on the mantises
forehead and then with tiny 3d glasses
that he's cut out previously hold smooth
tweezers and just pops them in place the
beeswax drives within seconds and then
the glasses are held in place in front
of the mantas eyes and you might think
they would be bothered by that but
actually they seem really indifferent to
it so can you elaborate a bit on
what kinds of images you're showing to
these mantises and then what you are
learning from how they're reacting to
such images so here I would like to
distinguish between basically three
prongs of our research we're pursuing
behavioral electrophysiological and
computational strands as research so the
behavior was trying to figure out okay
what can their stereo vision do how do
we break it what kind of images does it
work with what kind of images does it
not work with and this is something a
vision scientists do all the time and it
helps us figure out basically the
algorithms that the brain is using in
order to achieve 3d vision and that's
where the computational part comes in
and the thing is for the behavioral
experiments we're basically relying on
the animals to tell us what they can see
so they're experiencing a 3d illusion in
our experiments if they reach out and
catch or try and catch the virtual
object so the trouble is that limits us
because whatever we display has to be
attractive enough to Alyssa to strike if
the animal see something in 3d but isn't
interested it'll just sit there and then
of course we don't know is it seeing
anything is it not seeing anything so
the next first job was to try and figure
out a really attractive stimulus that
will drive the behavior really well and
what we've come up with was a black disc
that just spirals around the computer
screen getting in instead of decreasing
circles and it comes to rest just in
front of the Mantis and that really
seems to get them going so that was our
first stimulus that we use to basically
prove that the glasses were working and
having established that then we could
use more complicated images so we've
been using images mailer for black and
white patterns of dots and the reason
for this is we want to then manipulate
things like the correlation of the
pattern between the two I basically
human stereo vision works by cost
correlating the two eyes images so as
they're your brain is kind of sliding
across the images they are yet that is
the best match where the correlation is
highest and so that was my starting
point for mantis stereo vision so with
these random note patterns we
manipulated the correlation between the
left and right eye images we know
humans that totally messes with your 3d
vision but to our great surprise this
just didn't bother the mantids at all
they were able to carry on striking and
grabbing the virtual prey even when
there was no correlation at all between
the pattern of light and dark in the two
eyes images do you might say well if it
wasn't any combination
how could you define where the prey was
and the answer is it's the relation
where things are changing in the image
so it's a stereo vision that's based
entirely on motion or at least some
change and it actually as far as we know
doesn't work at all with static images
so it's really completely different in
that sense from our own human stereo
vision what were you doing to kind of
look inside the brains to determine what
is going on in the neurobiology here
when they are looking at these images by
the extremely talented postdoc money
wasn't there who's been looking at that
and that's been a real technical
challenge because even though he's
extremely experienced in in secondary
physiology people intend to work with
preying mantises so he had to figure out
how to get into their brains how to
record activity from individual neurons
nerve cells inside their brain and he
had to do this while they were watching
these 3d displays Ronnie's found neurons
in the Mantis brain which are tuned to
positions in 3d space so a neuron that
might like objects here or anyone that
might like objects over here and by like
I mean it's firing more spikes of
voltage and that seemed to be telling
the animal where things are in the space
around it so putting that all together
how would a system like that that's
going on in the the mantis insect brain
differ from how we humans perceive 3d
objects so we're still some work out the
details of that but the kind of alumina
B model I have in my mind at the moment
which we're trying to write computer
programs to instantiate to test is that
actually the take home for me is it's
much more similar to humans at the
neural level than I had expected we
thought originally that Manta stereopsis
might be super simple like maybe you
have inputs on the left I'm putting the
my time there combined
barely
so that you basically have an and gate
just before you decide whether described
and you see something in the left eye
and the right eye bingo
strike but actually mom is finding many
classes of neurons that attuned to
stereoscopic distance at all levels of
the brain and he's found feedback loops
so that's suggesting quite a complicated
circuit so I think it's been surprising
how similar the neural basis of 3d
vision seems to be in the insect
compared to the mammal but I think the
difference is maybe at the front end so
where is these computations in humans
are being done on the pattern of light
and dark in the two eyes in the Mantis
they seem to be done on the pattern of
change so where things are changing so I
personally that this research can stand
perfectly fine on its own it's it's
great these are awesome findings but
there's a bigger picture here I think
with applications toward robotics in
particular can you elaborate how you
might take what you've learned with this
study and then ply them to machines that
are moving around in the real world so
I'm very interested in this because I
tend to think of insects as kind of tiny
amazingly efficient robots and so of
course it's hugely interesting to think
how could we take what we learn from
insects and put it into robotics I take
two main lessons from what we've learned
so far about mantis stereopsis I think
working with change is a really
interesting idea and not something
that's been used a lot in the Machine
stereo literature so far and the fact
that it works so successfully for
mantids suggests to me that it might be
worth taking seriously for some robotic
applications again you'd have to think
carefully about the applications but you
know maybe if you have a drone that is
moving and wants to come and kick
something up just like amount is
catching a prey that as a particular
distance maybe it would work for that
kind of application well thank you for
taking the time to chat today absolute
pleasure thanks very much